I'm a sixth generation farmer I want
this land and these resources to be
available to my children and their
children and future Generations so
caranada has the potential to improve
soil Health has immediate benefits and
potentially long-term benefits as well
it's a crop with a high level of biomass
so if you consider like the nutrient
content and that new crop that's not
normally in the system being introduced
back into the rotation whether it's
cultivated and minimally or in a minimal
or no-till situation that decomposition
is going to just bring a level of
nutrients back to the to the soil
profile it's going to be available for
the next crop and because of the layer
of residue that it leaves behind you
have improvements in water retention and
nutrient retention for the next cash
crop for the farmers so there's all of
these benefits aside from having
Financial benefits for the grower
it's hard to get good nutrient and water
retention in our sandy soil caranata has
a great fit in our system it kind of
breaks up the monotony of the same crop
year after year or two crops in rotation
year after year by adding some
biodiversity into the soil putting in
nutrients back to the soil that we
didn't previously have introduced there
but the biggest thing is if there is
some economic benefit to the grower
market prices don't really change when
our commodity crops fertilizer costs
fuel costs continue to go up and up and
up and so if you add in a new crop into
a farming system that's very low input
and you get so many benefits from it in
terms of the soil Health aspect but also
an immediate benefit because it's a
harvestable grain crop
foreign